Now that you know what
Android resources are,
and that you can put them
in different folders.
Let's talk about how you can actually
access the resources that you saved in
those folders.
When your app is compiled,
there's a tool in Android called AAPT.
And that generates the R class.
This is simply an R.Java file, and
I'll show you an example next.
It contains the resource IDs for all
the resources in your S directory, so
for all the resources that you've added,
there's an ID to refer to it.
The ID is in a format that is
based on the resource type, so for
all Java resources which are graphics it
would follow the format of R.drawable.
For all strings that are resources,
it would follow the formula
R.string.resource name which
is hello in this case.
Note there are two ways that
you can access a resource.
In Java code it follows the format of
R.resource type.resource name In XML
though, it follows the at notation, so
it would be at and then the resource
type would be string slash, and
then the resource name, which is hello.
Here are more examples of different
resource types and how to access them.
These are just a couple of
the common resource types,
but there are many others.
You always start with R, a dot,
and then resource type, a dot,
and then the resource name.
And the name is whatever you assign it.
And then in XML you have @ and
then the resource type, slash,
and then the name of the resource.
Let's take a moment to find
all the resource IDs in
our main activity Java file.
I'm going to open up the find
command in Android Studio.
I'm going to use Cmd+F, or
you can use Ctrl+F if you're on Windows.
It pops up a search field here.
I'm going to search for
capital R dot, and
then click on match case, so
that it only grabs the capital R cases.
The first thing it finds is this
r.layout.activity_main reference.
This is interesting because we're
referring to the activity main
layout file.
This is actually how the main activity
knows to load up this XML file.
Isn't that cool?
Let's look at the next reference.
Okay.
In the displayQuantity method,
we have a reference to
R.id.quantity_text_view.
So this is referring to a ViewId.
Specifically, the TextView
that displays the quantity.
Hopefully some of the puzzle
pieces are coming together.
By referring to this
view in the Java code.
We can update it while the app is
running to show this numberOfCoffees.
Let's go to the next occurance.
OK in the displayMessage
method we see a reference to
R.id.order_summary_text_view.
Here it seems like we're trying to
refer to this text view which displays
the order summary, so
that we can update it with this message.